what I have listed here is several of
the derivative rules that we've used in
previous videos if these things look
unfamiliar to you I encourage you maybe
to not watch this video because in this
video we're going to think about when do
we apply these rules what strategies and
can we algebraically convert expressions
so that we can use a simpler rule but
just as a quick review this is of course
the power rule right over here very
handy for taking derivatives of X raised
to some power it's also we can use that
with the derivative properties of sums
of derivatives or drift or differences
of derivatives to take derivatives of
polynomials this right over here is the
product rule if I have an expression I
want to take the derivative of and I can
think of it as the product of two
functions well then the derivative is
going to be the derivative of the first
function times the second function plus
the first function times the derivative
of the second once again if this looks
completely unfamiliar to you or it's a
little your little shaky go watch the
videos do the practice on the power rule
or the product rule or in this case the
quotient rule and the quotient rule is a
little bit more involved and then we
have practice and videos on that and I
always have mixed feelings about it
because if you don't remember the
quotient rule
you can usually or you can always
convert a quotient into a product by
expressing this thing at the bottom as f
of X or by expressing this as f of X
times G of X to the negative one so you
could take the derivative with a
combination of the products and this
fourth rule over here the chain rule and
if any of this if any of this is looking
unfamiliar again don't watch this video
this video is for folks who are familiar
with each of these derivative rules or
derivative techniques and now I want to
think about what what our strategies for
deciding when to apply which so let's do
that let's say that I have the
expression let's say I'm interested in
taking the derivative of x squared plus
X minus 2 over X minus 1 which of these
rules or techniques would you use
well you might immediately say hey look
this is look like a rational expression
I could say look I could say this is my
f of X right over here I could say this
is my G of X right over here and I could
apply the quotient rule this looks like
a quotient of two expressions and you
could do that and if you do all the
mathematics correctly you will get the
correct answer but in this case it's
good to just take a little time to
realize well can I simplify this
algebraically so maybe I can do a little
bit less work and if you look at it that
way you might realize like what if I
factored this numerator I can factor it
as X plus 2 times X minus 1 and then I
could cancel these two characters out
and say hey you know what this is going
to be the same thing as the derivative
with respect to X of X plus 2 derivative
with respect to X of X plus 2 which is
much much much much much more
straightforward than trying to apply the
quotient rule here you just take the
derivative with respect to X of X which
is just going to be 1 and the derivative
with respect to X of 2 is just going to
be 0 and so all of this is just going to
simplify to 1 for taking the derivative
of that you're essentially just using
the power rule and so once again just a
simple algebraic recognition things
become much much much much more simple
let's do another example so let's say
that you you were to see or someone were
to ask you to take the derivative with
respect to X of let me see so let's say
you had x squared plus 2x minus 5 over
over X so once again you might be
tempted to use the quotient rule this
looks like the quotient of two
expressions but then you might realize
well there's some algebraic
manipulations I can do to make this
simpler you could express this as a
product you could say that this is the
same thing as and I'm just going to
focus on what's inside the parenthesis
or inside the brackets this is the same
thing as X to the negative 1
times x squared plus 2x minus 5 and then
you might want to apply the product rule
but there's even a better simplification
here you could just divide each of these
terms by X or one way to think about it
distribute this 1 over X across all the
terms x to the negative 1 is the same
thing as 1 over X and if you do that x
squared divided by X is going to be X to
X divided by X is going to be 2 and then
negative 5 divided by X well you could
write that as negative 5 over X or
negative 5 X to the negative 1 and now
taking the derivative of this with
respect to X is much easier than using
either the quotient or the power rule
this is going to be let's use derivative
of that it's just going to be one
derivative of 2 is just going to be 0
and here even though you have a negative
exponent it might look a little
intimidating this is just take it using
the power rule so negative 1 times
negative 5 is positive 5x to the if we
take one less than negative 1 we're
going to go to the negative 2 power so
once again making this algebraic
recognition simplified things a good bit
let's do a few more examples of just
starting to recognize when we might be
able to simplify things to do things a
little bit easier so let's say that
someone said hey you take take the
derivative with respect to X and I'm
using X as our variable that we're
taking the derivative with respect to
but obviously this works for for any
variables that we are using so let's say
we're saying square root of x over x
squared pause this video and think about
how would you approach this if you want
to take the derivative with respect to X
of the square root of x over x squared
well once again you might say this is a
quotient of two expressions might try to
apply the quotient rule or you might
recognize well look this is this is the
same thing let me just focus on what's
inside the brackets you could view this
as X to the negative 2 times the square
root of x times the square root of x and
then you might want to use a product
rule but you could simplify this even
better you could say this is the same
thing as X to the neck
two times X to the 1/2 power and I just
using our exponent properties negative 2
plus 1/2 is negative 3 halves so this is
the derivative of X to the negative 3
halves power and so here once again we
took something that we thought we might
have to use a quotient rule or use from
the pot use the product rule and now
this just becomes a straightforward
using the power rule so this is just
going to be equal to so bring the
negative three-halves out front negative
3 halves X to the negative 3 halves
minus 1 is negative 5 halves power so
once again just before you just
especially if you're about to apply the
quotient rule and sometimes even the
product rule just see is there is there
an algebraic simplification sometimes
the trigonometric simplification that
you can make that that eases your job it
makes things less hairy and as a general
tip I can't say this is going to be
always true but if you're taking some
type of an exam and you're going down
some really hairy route which the
quotient rule will often take you it's a
good sign that he take a pause before
trying to run through all of that
algebra to apply the quotient rule and
see if you can simplify things so let's
give another example and this one
there's not an there's not a must
there's not an obvious way and it really
depends on what focuses preferences are
but let's say you want to take the
derivative with respect to X of 1 over
2x to the negative 5 sorry 1 over 2x
minus 5 I should say well here you could
immediately you could apply the quotient
rule here or the numerator you view you
view that as f of X you could view this
is the same thing as the derivative with
respect to X instead of 2x minus 5 we do
that in the blue color 2x minus 5 to the
negative 1 power and now this in this
situation you would use a combination of
the power rule and the chain rule you'd
say okay my G of X is 2x minus 5 and
F of G of X is going to be this whole
expression and so if you did if you
applied the chain rule
this is going to be the derivative of
the outside function our f of X with
respect to the inside function so or the
derivative F of G of X with respect to G
of X so it's going to be negative we'll
bring that negative out front so
essentially just going to use the power
rule here negative 2x minus 5 to the
negative 2 and then we multiply that
times the derivative of x the derivative
of the inside function so the inside
functions derivative the derivative 2x
is 2 derivative negative 5 is 0 so it's
going to be times 2 and of course you
can simplify it so it's negative 2 times
all of this business let me do one more
example here just to hit the point home
and once again there isn't a must way
there's a way that you have to do this
but just let you appreciate that there's
multiple ways to approach these types of
derivatives so let's say someone said
take the derivative of 2x plus 1 squared
pause the video and think about how you
would do that well one way to do it is
just to apply the chain rule just like
we just did so you could say all right
it's going to be the derivative of the
outside with respect to the inside so
it's going to be 2 times 2x plus 1 to
the first power taking 1 less than that
times the derivative of the inside which
is just going to be 2 and so this is
going to be equal to 4 times 2x plus 1
which is equal to week if we want to
distribute the 4 we could say it's 8x
plus 4 that's a completely legitimate
way of doing it now there are other ways
of doing it you could expand out to X
plus 1 squared you could say this is the
same thing as the derivative with
respect to X of 2x squared is going to
be 4x squared and then 2 times the
product of these terms is going to be
plus 4x plus 1 and now you would just
apply the power rule so a little bit of
extra algebra up front but you can just
go straight forward with the power rule
and you're going to get this exact same
thing so the whole takeaway here is
pause look at your expression see if
there's a way to
simplify it and it's especially a good
thing if you can get out of using the
quotient rule because that sometimes
it's just hard to know or remember and
even when you do remember it can get
quite hairy quite fast